[Music]
let's go out to Richmond Virginia and
talk to Chris hey Chris what's up hey
John how's it going I'm doing fantastic
my man what are you up
to hey uh on my lunch break right now
but uh I got a question or I guess it's
more of a I think it's a mental block
issue um so the basically
I I am not constantly motivated to lose
weight and despite worries from family
and doctors doctor every time I go into
the doctor's office uh they say my BMI
is off the charts um what is it and all
that um uh 50 something which which is
not good I know okay um but the kicker
is um back in high school I was I was
basically a gym rat um really cuz it was
the only way I was going to make and get
playing time on the football team like I
remember
coaches um actually tell me to stop
lifting uh for free fear of overtraining
or injuring myself so the motivation has
been there for me in the past I just
can't
find that Conant motivation that I used
to have back in high school when I was
uh constantly uh playing playing sports
all the time yeah well man it takes a
lot for grow man how old are you brother
I am uh 33 Okay it takes a lot for 33y
old man to call in and say I'm stuck so
I applaud you my brother congratulations
dude thanks it's
awesome
um I'm GNA ask you a weird question is
that okay okay yeah go ahead we're going
to start talking about motivation we're
not going to end here but I want to
start with it what did um playing time
in in in high school sports high school
football what did they get
you um just it it felt it felt worth it
when I would uh playing games more than
others and also just yeah it felt
rewarding it felt like the hard work was
paying
off how did you get that reward did did
your old man Pat you on the back did
your mom smile real big did the coaches
grab your face mask and say I'm proud of
you like how did that reward come to
you oh it was self-rewarding oh I I no
no family no coaches uh were pushing me
it was it was all me that was pushing
myself like this um like I said Co the
coaches would tell me hey hey Chris stop
working out you're gonna hurt yourself
we're afraid afraid you're going
overheat when when you're doing all
these extra Sprints in the summer before
two a day start this was all
all my whole my own personal me
mentality and it was just I mean your
mom and dad didn't highfive you a little
bit extra or anything like that no I
would uh I would actually get mad at my
mom when she would text me after
losses my mom was always positive and I
I I would get mad at her when she was
trying to cheer me up after losses I I I
just wasn't in the mood to hear it okay
so um you graduated high school then
what happened then where'd you go
um went to college at West Virginia
University
um did all the and and then that's where
all the weight game started um from
doing normal things that a college stre
would do but I would also I
um I would play on the club rugby team
in the spring they they had a fall
season but uh I went to college to get
into sports broadcasting so so in the
fall I was busy covering the football
team so I would just play on the club
rugby team in the spring okay well
sometimes it's as simple as this um in
fact I've I've met with some college
athletes before who have to go through a
period um this is my language not theirs
of down regulation they're they're they
train so hard um that their caloric
intake they can eat so much if you want
to Google like what Michael Phelps used
to eat it was like 10,000 calories a day
and he was shredded because of his pool
workouts were were madous right and so
College athletes often find and like you
mentioned like intensive high school
athletes often find that when the season
is over when those two days plus the
extra weight room sessions plus the
workouts plus the games uh when those
end abruptly are eating habits often
remain the same and then you go to a
college where you have a cafeteria plan
that's all you can
eat and man that's a that's a it's just
a recipe for an almost overnight
physiology change right your body just
changes and it's really hard to get that
sucker back going again um but you're 33
now right and here's my bigger question
people who love you have said hey Chris
we're worried about you your doctors
looked at you and said brother I'm
worried about you I make money when
you're not well and I'm worried about
you the one person that's not worried
about Chris is Chris how
come uh I don't know that that's why I
was calling to see calling you to see
what type of mental block this is or
tryy different because I I I I've looked
up all this stuff I understand eat a
bunch of protein no no no no hold on
Chris Chris Chris Chris has nothing to
do with that right now okay none of
that um I don't know if you heard the
previous call with my friend Sal the
step of Mind pump and I and I want to uh
I want to strongly encourage you to
begin listening to that
show um okay
but he's the one who told me hey John
you can't you can't long-term workout
and exercise and eat right because you
think you're
gross so Chris you're not going to be
able to
maintain I want to lose weight because
these people are telling me I have
to in fact most of the data would
suggest that even facing a terminal
diagnostic if you don't do this you're
going to die that is often not enough of
a primer for Behavior
change it has to be Chris believes I'm
worth feeling good when I wake up I want
to sleep really
well I don't know if you're married or
not but I want my marriage to be wild
and
fun I want to be able to roll around on
the on the ground with my grandkids with
my own
kids and that starts with you looking in
the mirror and saying I'm worth feeling
good and that means I'm worth taking
care of myself it's the same as saving
money I don't want to be um on
government um subsidies when I'm 65
years old simply because I spent all my
money as a kid so that's why I'm going
to save some of my
money right right it's because I value
future me so my question to you is not
about protein intake and exercise
programs and all that that stuff quite
honestly is
simple the harder thing is Chris why
don't you think you're worth feeling
well uh I honestly I I can't think of an
answer
okay like I I know I need to do it no
it's not about that it's about do you
like the life you've created for
Chris
um I like everything except for my uh
weight right now okay are you
married uh no I am uh single okay and I
living alone okay are you lonely as
bloody
hell uh yeah I would say so if I'm
looking at um uh dogs on the dog shelter
websites every day yeah you have a group
of of dude buddies y'all hang out with
on a regular basis once a week y'all go
hang out
yeah tell
jokes yeah play dominoes make fun of
each other a little bit check in with
each
other uh
yeah I think the question to answer here
is um is
Chris is Chris worth a better
life and here's why that's an important
question and I'm going to answer it for
you the answer is yes there's no
question in my mind here's why that
that's
important looking for motivation is a
waste of your time because motivation
comes and goes man it's like great
weather every once in a while the
weather is just stunning and you stop
and you just you take it all in but most
of the time it's a little cold it's a
little hot it's way too cold it's way
too hot it just kind of is motivation is
not a sustainable Life Force at all
ever in fact motivation is designed to
keep you from dying which is an
emergency flush the system get out of
here go run right
now but discipline I keep showing up for
my kids because I love them and they're
worth me showing up even when I would
rather do
anything than actually show up I want to
sleep I want to rest I want to go read
this book I want to go on a hunting trip
I want to go do some other
things but man my kids are worth a dad
that shows up so I'm going to show
up so I don't wait on motivation I could
care less about
motivation so here's my um I'm gonna set
you up and then I'm going to challenge
you okay okay here's what I'm going G to
set you up with my friend Dr Lane Norton
has the single best um Fitness Tracker
app on the planet it's the one I use
it's the one Andrew huberman uses it's
the one Dr Norton himself created and he
uses it and he is a multi-time
weightlifting champion and a PhD in
nutritional physiology okay it's the
best of the best I'm gonna hook you up
for a year for free okay okay I'm also
going to hook you up with two of any of
the workouts on mine pump's
website they have a 15minute program for
busy people they've got an hour and a
half program for people who are trying
to transform everything um I'm going to
hook you up with all of that that you
need okay okay and both Dr Norton and
um the mine pump my my friends at mine
pump and uh Jordan s s y a TT you can
follow him on Instagram that's going to
be all the nutritional advice you need
okay okay so here's what I've just
solved for you the workout plan done
free um stay on the line and we're going
to hook you up with their contact
information they're going to hook you up
with it the tracking app to actually
like make sure your your your energy
expend which is nerd speak for making
sure you are eating fewer calories in
you're burning done got that and you
want to just scroll on social media done
got you the guy to follow okay so I've
taken care of the nuts and bolts part
here you never have to Google workout
plan again I got you mind pump's got
that taken care of you never have to
Google like protein ratio done Dr Norton
and Jordan s have got you on that okay
here's your homework assignment for
me okay I want you to write college
graduate Chris a
letter Dear Chris
okay I'm 30 you're 33 years old now and
here's the life I've built for
us I live here here's where I
work I'm not married trying to find a
dog and if I'm being honest Chris
there's going to be part of you that re
like kicking butt doing good got a group
of guy friends we we hang out got a good
job
whatever there going to be part of you
that your shoulders drop and there's a
there's some grief there because college
graduate
Chris probably had a different picture
in his mind of 33-year-old Chris is that
fair definitely okay I want you to feel
that but I don't want that to be shame I
don't want you to beat yourself up for
it because here we are right m and now
we got tools and then I want you to
write a second
letter to 50-year-old
Chris Dear
Chris you're 33 and this is the day that
we chose to change
everything I love you enough I love my
future wife enough I love our future
kids enough I love my neighbors enough I
love those friends that I hang out with
enough I'm gonna feel good in my life
I love my customers enough in my
business I'm gonna start feeling
good and it's bro don't go start a 4H
hour workout program tomorrow
morning I want you to commit to going
for a walk four times a week for 10 or
15 minutes that's
it okay I want you to start drinking
some more water and once you get that
done for 30 days we're going to add a
few more then we're going to add a
couple more then we're going to add a
couple
more
I'm in better shape right this minute in
my mid 40s than I was in my
mid-30s and I didn't get there overnight
it took me a decade
okay the last homework assignment so you
got two letters to
write is I want you to go to the mirror
every single
day for 30
days and I want you to make a fist in
your right hand and I want you to put it
in your
chest and I want you to look yourself in
the eyes in the mirror and say 10
times I love this
guy and I want you to drop your
shoulders and relax I want you to look
yourself in the eye in the mirror and
put your hand in your chest I want you
say I love this
guy because somewhere along the way you
lost that spark not for the world but
for
Chris M is that
fair yeah that that's fair is it is it
sounding cheesy or is it touching the
nerve no it definitely sound sound
sounds achievable
okay I believe in you and by the way the
way you were living in high school
wasn't healthy either we're not going
back to
that right
okay being a maniac on either side of
the Teeter Totter isn't
helpful MH what we're looking for is a
really healthy 50-year-old Chris that
loves waking up every
morning oh yeah it doesn't feel like
exercise but I'm going to go do
something I'm going to go get it in I'm
gonna put some money in the bank for
Chris because I love Chris and then when
I love Chris and Chris is able to love
his family and his friends and his
community and his neighbors does that
sound fair yep that's fair thank you all
right two other things I'm gonna do I'm
gonna send you a copy of my latest book
building a non-anxious life also I want
you to read that
book I'm also going to send you a copy
of my friend kin Coleman's book paycheck
to
purpose because almost always when
somebody starts down on an adventure of
of asking themselves why don't I like
myself I'm pretty good guy I want to
take an inventory of the life I've built
for myself you start asking yourself
relationship questions physical and
mental health questions and then you
start asking yourself occupation
questions do I like this job is this job
killing
me so that book is a asking yourself
it's it's an inventory it's a path to
job place where you spend a lot of your
day is this what I want to do is just
the best way I can serve my community
help people down the road with Business
Solutions and make a great living for
myself so I'm going to hook you up man
I'm going to give you all the tools and
I want you to write yourself your old
self a letter your future self a letter
and I want you to take your present self
and look in the mirror and say dude I am
worth
this happy New Year my
brother call me in about six months
whenever Everything Changes I cannot
wait